voir on va faire une interview au matin
je suis pas chanter marie vous me
répondez vous me répondez chanter quand
vous avez chanté la chanson est pas
chanter quand voulait pas chanter
on va voir à marée haute à marée basse
oui non non chanter c'est quoi à marée
haute
non l'ambré pompe son nom sur une
passion que je ne chanterai pas sur
scène en scène
alors on y va à marée haute à marée
basse wissant t aime moi jusqu'à demain
sachant chanter ah ben on gagne et faire
chanter sainte et chanter à chanter m
moins 30 secondes de plus ça changera ah
non non non mais si untel c'est pour
voir c'est en tout cas tête alzheimer
après toi qui sais oui santé barbecue
n'ont pas chanté chanteur n'a pas chanté
barbecue bah oui en anglais à leur vieux
rival baseball magazine
ouais santé c'est julien julie régime
c'est jean-michel non c'est pas chanter
sa jeunesse j'ai pas grand mais c'est
sympa
oui mais santé dont on ne doit que d
amor dessinée elles sont bien c'est pas
grand mais je regrette et en plus c'est
tout moi donc ça passe bien chou
cailloux genou époux est purement c'est
moi mais wade encore ni car non paulo
elle pensé clarita gilet en laine non
bon alors je prétends que c'est moi qui
fais les questions que l'on sait
maintenant contre liverpool
oui roubles et mulhouse n'ont pu le
générique du para oui mais les blues ont
pris non saint tropez blues siffler je
siffle ma fille oui je suce ma fille
très jolie très jolies tenues tout fallu
que celle au tulle et de faim je te
sentais chanter ça me sentais bien sûr
oui oui voilà bien longtemps que l'on
tuait des en plus tu pues marron très
triste et très bien bien bien bien bien
bien sûr la montagne
malheureusement oui oui je viens oui je
viens non non non non wawa vaches java
oui 13e ses devoirs sahwa et mourir oui
non non c'est moi l'amour comme à une
autre oui bien c'est d'abord chez moi
l'amour comme à 16 ans et je ne
connaissais pas fais moi l'amour que n'a
eu d'autre que j'ai entendu pour la
première fois il ya quinze j'ai bien
l'ordre je suis folle de vous et vous
ici fall de vous chanter santé le
suffolk tout court oui
santé n'ont pas chômé la santé johnny
guitar hero t chanter si et mais si tu
la chanteuse amy lee tard c'est mon sens
l'accordéon de santé johnny guitare
vient de jeunes éditeurs en août
tu t'y connais à mort c'est incroyable
la une de jeunesse manque la tour de
babel
il vient au feu de bois
c'est un piège de blocs de bois c'est
passante et non c'est l'amour au feu de
bois
ah oui le toit et chante avec moi oui si
santé lève toi et marche
nos fils n'est pas santé c'est bien il a
neigé sur yesterday
ouais il a pissé sur les machines ont le
regret de l'avoir fait mais tarde à
venir